[Musik]
smartphone social media immer online nur
einen klick entfernt von der nächsten
story dem nächsten post dem nächsten -
endlich möglichkeiten uns zu entfalten
und trotzdem scheint es als würde uns
das netz nicht immer gut tun was ist in
den letzten jahren mit uns geschehen und
welche rolle spielen die sozialen medien
bei aldingen das netz und die sozialen
medien sind teil meines jobs
doch der preis dafür ist hoch ich zahle
mit meinen sensibelsten daten und mit
meiner lebenszeit hier meine
durchschnittliche bildschirmzeit pro tag
beträgt über acht stunden schlafen tue
ich nur sechs stunden
aber es geht nicht nur um unsere zeit
und unsere daten auf social media
scheint es kein korrektiv zu geben
der hass aus dem netz entlädt sich immer
häufiger auf der straße
so wie in washington oder berlin was
können wir selbst tun um uns zu schützen
und wo beginnt die politische
verantwortung
unsere recherche beginnt in berlin wo
wir erfahren was social media mit
unserer psyche macht die reise nach
brüssel und sehen wie groß der druck der
lobby auf die politik ist in irland
entdecken wir wie fahrlässig mit unseren
daten umgegangen wird
was ich mich frage ist wie kann man
ausgerechnet eine der wichtigsten
eu-behörden hierhin versetzen
[Musik]
wir benutzen das jeden tag nach dem
aufstehen checken wir erst einmal unsere
daimler indes privat nachrichten und
mails wir denken wie kommentieren und
informieren uns wir bleiben mit freunden
und der familie in kontakt auf der
ganzen welt
wir lieben es aber manchmal hassen wir
es auch wenn wir nicht loskommen von
unseren bildschirm und den feed aber
tausende male aktualisieren während
stunde um stunde vergeht nur will das
keiner zugeben in einer welt in der sich
unser selbstwert regelmäßig an unserer
produktivität bemisst haben wir das
alles noch unter kontrolle
oder sind wir schon längst verloren ich
bin richard gutjahr journalist und
blogger ich verfolge die debatte um das
netz schon seit anfang an und ich frage
mich warum wir der wachsenden macht der
digital konzerne ausgeliefert zu sein
scheinen mein name ist nehmen lassen
ich bin ärzten und journalisten ich
merke immer wieder wie mich social media
runterzieht obwohl ich es doch
eigentlich besser wissen müsste manche
wissenschaftler innen sprechen
mittlerweile von einer onlinesucht sie
haben einen fragebogen entwickelt mit
dem es möglich sein soll hinweise auf
eine solche sucht zu erfassen
du fühlst eindrang social media häufiger
zu nutzen als zuletzt und tust ich
glaube ich nutze schon so häufig dass
dann geht keine steigerung du benutzt
social media um persönliche probleme von
dir zu vergessen oder ihnen aus dem weg
zu gehen
sehr selten seiten manchmal häufig sehr
häufig ich bin nur ehrlich ich habe
jetzt ein ergebnis bekommt jetzt
immerhin zeigen high end action
nein das schockt mich jetzt muss ich
gleich mal twitter hilfst du dich jetzt
so als abhängiger
wie ich mich jetzt fühle als abhängiger
also dafür braucht keine studie dass das
natürlich ich bin total
das ist die fernbedienung meines lebens
aber ich find's ganz spannend weil mir
geht es da eigentlich so ein bisschen
anders als dir also einerseits benutze
ich social media auch viel zu häufig
aber ich habe nie das gefühl dass ich so
irgendwas wertvolles zurückbekommen
würde sondern ist auch mehr energie und
trotzdem komme ich davon nicht weg also
für mich klingt das produkt ohr du bist
süchtig süchtig oder nicht zwei drei
fragen alleine reichen für eine solche
diagnose sicher nicht aus trotzdem ein
testergebnis gibt mir zu denken
wie haben es die tech unternehmen
geschafft mich derart an ihre produkte
zu gewöhnen dass ich mein telefon kaum
noch aus der hand legen egal ist ein tag
insider sein bestseller hockt gilt im
silicon valley als eine art bauanleitung
dafür wie man apps so programmiert dass
wir möglichst lange vor dem bildschirm
gefesselt bleiben in jupiter scraping
social media is being born this way all
sieht nicht etwa die konzerne sondern
vor allem die nutzerinnen selbst in der
pflicht wenn es darum geht den eigenen
online konsum einzudämmen
und trotzdem verbringt jeder deutsche
täglich rund dreieinhalb stunden im netz
bei jugendlichen und jungen erwachsenen
sind es etwa sechseinhalb stunden
während der pandemie sind die zahlen
noch weiter angestiegen und wer viel
online ist gibt auch häufiger an sich
nervös oder depressiv zu fühlen
das wort sucht fällt häufig im
zusammenhang mit social media aber nicht
jedes unbehagen hängt direkt mit einer
sucht zusammen
ich will wissen was es mit diesem gefühl
auf sich hat das so viele von uns spüren
und frage jemanden der es wissen muss
also es gibt keinen kippschalter im
gehirn der eine sucht erzeugt sondern
eine sucht ist eine beschreibung von
verhaltensweisen zu dem gehört
einerseits die gewöhnung meistens an die
droge oder anders verhalten und die
entzugssymptome equens wegfällt und zum
anderen der starke verlangen andreas
heinz sagt die sogenannte onlinesucht
spiele im klinischen alltag keine rolle
trotzdem lesen und hören wir ständig von
dem begriff der bis heute keine diagnose
darstellt stattdessen sei es nötig sich
anzusehen was genau im netz gemacht wird
professor heinz sieht das konzept hinter
einer allgemeinen onlinesucht sehr
kritisch ich werde mit dem begriff sehr
vorsichtig denn man macht online ja
viele sachen die einen vielleicht
schädigen können aber der durchaus
wichtig sind zum beispiel politisches
blocken denken sie an länder in denen
man was mich frei tun darf und wir
wollen doch nicht dass solche personen
dann mit einer suchterkrankung noch in
klinik eingewiesen werden bisher
etabliert ist gaming und gameplay es ist
sicherlich nicht falsch auch bei anderen
personen darüber nachzudenken ob sucht
artige züge trägt aber man muss eben
immer mit den klassifikationen
vorsichtig sein man hat und intendierte
konsequenzen sind soziale medien schon
so gebaut dass sie theoretisch abhängig
machen können
das kann glaube ich auf die dichte der
interaktionsmöglichkeiten anja wenn sie
einen ganz einfaches altes glücksspiel
denken in der kneipe wird dann ist hier
schneller die laufen und bimmeln desto
mehr können die abhängig machen deswegen
sind dies wissen viele nicht in der
geschwindigkeit gedrosselt und bei
sozialen medien kommt wirklich darauf an
was sie tun und wie schnell die
rückmeldungen kommen all das macht quasi
letztendlich aus ob so ein system wie
das sogenannte belohnungssystem noch
anspringt oder nicht
die algorithmen der sozialen plattformen
zählen genau auf dieses bildungssystem
ab einer komplexen struktur in unserem
gehirn so bleiben wir möglichst lang
online
algorithmen sind mathematische formeln
die informationen über unser online
verhalten sammeln und auf dieser
grundlage entscheiden welche inhalte uns
angezeigt werden die also in jeder
sekunde unsere online realität
erschaffen dass das problematisch ist
sagt selbst der twitter chef der
algorithmus scheint unser innerstes zu
kennen während wir so gut wie nichts
wissen nichts darüber welche daten die
digital unternehmen über uns sammeln was
mit ihnen geschieht und welche
konsequenzen das für uns alle haben kann
und was bleibt ist ein dumpfes gefühl
des ausgeliefertseins das
geschäftsmodell von facebook und co
besteht darin möglichst viel und zu
interaktionen anzuregen mit dem ziel
letztendlich muss passende werbeplätze
anbieten zu können damit verdient man
sein geld
markus beckedahl ist netzaktivist und
journalist erhält die art und weise wie
die algorithmen der sozialen medien
agieren für problematisch ein
algorithmus ist in der regel nicht
komplett unabhängig in seiner
entscheidung sondern algorithmische
entscheidungs systeme greifen ja auch
bestehende datensätze zurück wenn ein
algorithmus entscheidungssystem halt
sehr viele wut inhalte mit postings
sozusagen als basis hat und feststellte
dass sind beiträge die haben
offensichtlich sehr viele menschen zu
einer interaktion angeregt dann kommt so
ein algorithmus möglicherweise und sehr
wahrscheinlich auch zu dem entschluss
dass interessiert viele andere auch die
plattformen belohnen hetze mit mehr
sichtbarkeit und werden damit zu
gehilfen des hasses trotzdem für große
teile der weltbevölkerung werden online
news immer wichtiger
aber auch hier bei uns nutzen laut einer
studie des räubers instituts menschen
unter 49 jahren als
hauptinformationsquelle das netz
besonders soziale medien gewinnen dabei
an relevanz für mehr als jeden dritten
deutschen sind soziale netzwerke die
wichtigste informationsquelle bei den
besonders jungen bezieht sogar jeder
zweite seine nachrichten vor allem über
facebook instagram oder youtube kein
wunder dass sich dabei falsch
nachrichten verbreiten wie ein lauffeuer
denn mal ganz ehrlich wie oft checken
werden den wahrheitsgehalt einer
nachricht die wir bekommen vor allem
wenn sie von einem freund oder einer
freundin kommt ob falsch oder war den
plattformen kann das herzlich egal sein
denn sie verdienen am ende
jede zwölfte person in deutschland gibt
an schon einmal von hate speech im netz
betroffen gewesen zu sein
einer von ihnen ist muhammad amjahid er
ist autor und journalist in der
vergangenheit hat er sich unter anderem
mit rechten strukturen innerhalb der
sicherheitsorgane beschäftigt hast
nachrichten auf twitter hält er fast
täglich hört man sich dabei wenn man
ständig diesem hass ausgesetzt ist also
ich werde dich ständig mit hass
konfrontiert und über jahre habe ich
mich daran gewöhnt dieser hass rassismus
diese menschenfreundlichkeit sexismus
feindlichkeit ich würde nicht mehr quasi
überhaupt arbeiten oder reden oder ab
oder recherchieren können will ich mich
davon abhalten würde in büchern entlädt
sich der hass aus dem netz auf der
straße das sind kontinuitäten das kann
man glaube ich gar nicht so trennen also
das beste beispiel sind prominente
frauen oder autorinnen die halt
morddrohungen bekommen im netz diese
morddrohungen bleiben ja nicht nur im
virtuellen raum und also es ist wirklich
hätte teil des alltags und muss auch
dementsprechend auch betrachtet werden
das ist auswirkungen auf konkrete
münchen leben einfach hat
viele massaker und anschläge der letzten
jahre wurden vorher im netz angekündigt
ein beispiel dafür
der mord an walter lübke im voraus
hatten rechtsextreme und terroristen
jahrelang im netz gegen den politiker
gehetzt
auch die politikerin renate künast hat
ihre einschlägigen erfahrungen mit dem
rechten hass im netz gemacht
ich habe angefangen mich mit
rechtsextremismus zu beschäftigen wie er
sich entwickelt vor jahrzehnten
und ich sehe deshalb auch systematisch
dass es gar nicht um mich geht es geht
um mich es geht nicht um sie es geht
darum dass die systematisch das land
zersetzen würden die größte gefahr ist
dass die plattform einen raum bieten wo
sich systematischen verletzungen von
menschen und bürgerrechten organisieren
lässt
das ist eine gefahr für die demokratie
das müssen wir umdrehen was passiert
wenn ein totalitäres regime mit viel
geld und aufwand gezielt des
informationen auf den sozialen medien
betreibt kann man am beispiel von
myanmar sie im jahr 2017 haben
buddhistische extremisten angehörige
einer muslimischen minderheit gelyncht
schätzungsweise 25.000 der rohingya
musliminnen wurden ermordet
unzählige frauen vergewaltigt den
massakern vorangegangen waren
hasskampagnen und verleumdungen auf
facebook betrieben durch das militär
die un spricht von ethnischen
säuberungen und von einem genozid
wie kann es sein dass soziale
plattformen wie facebook oder youtube
solche hasskampagnen nicht unterbinden
dass sie jegliche verantwortung von sich
weisen
und damit auch noch durchkommen wir
fahren nach brüssel
dort werden in gremien und ausschüssen
die regularien verhandelt den sich die
tech unternehmen beugen müssen wenn sie
in der eu geschäfte machen wollen 2018
musste facebook chef mark zuckerberg vor
dem eu-parlament fragen beantworten
damals brachte das wenig neues bei einer
anhörung vor dem us-kongress räumte
zuckerberg ein dass facebook stärker
reguliert werden müsste so wie es die
europäische politik gerade versucht das
eu parlament hinter den kulissen tobt
ein kampf um den zugang zu rund 450
millionen eu bürger innen derzeit
verhandelt wird der digital services act
kurz die usa ein gesetz das tech
konzerne dazu verpflichten würde hate
speech einzudämmen
für die unternehmen geht es dabei vor
allem um das gute image was die konzerne
am liebsten verhindern wollen ist ein
zweites gesetz aus brüssel den digital
markets act die eu will verbieten dass
google und co ihre eigenen produkte im
netz bevorzugen mehr transparenz bei der
werbung soll zur pflicht werden und
nutzer innen sollen vorinstallierte
software von ihren geräten entfernen
dürfen
all das würde die unternehmen
milliardenkosten wir treffen felix duffy
er arbeitet für die ngo lobbycontrol und
beobachtet die social media konzerne
seit jahren
die unternehmen investieren viel geld um
gesetze zu verhindern die für sie am
ende noch teurer werden könnten
felix dafür zeigt uns wo die lobby büros
in brüssel liegen
dass apple hier stehen wir vor dem büro
von microsoft amazon und facebook alle
unweit des eu-parlaments gelegen
von außen unscheinbar von innen mächtig
und einflussreich wie viel lassen sich
die tech unternehmen diesen einfluss auf
die politik posten und das jetzt die
kugel vertretung
google ist von einem unternehmen das
unternehmen mit knapp sechs millionen
was am meisten für lobbyarbeit ausgibt
und unter den fünf unternehmen mit den
höchsten lobby ausgaben sind mit google
microsoft und facebook drei digital
konzerne und das zeigt einfach dass
diese branche ja gerade sehr viele
glauben steckt die fünf größten us
digital unternehmen geben doppelt so
viel geld für ihre lobbyarbeit in
brüssel aus wie die gesamte mächtiger
autoindustrie zusammen
wir treffen alexandra diese sie arbeitet
als schatten berichterstatterin am dsl
dass die unternehmen immer mehr druck
ausüben spürt sie deutlich das problem
was ich habe als als abgeordnete ist das
eigentlich überall einfluss dieser
unternehmen mit drin steckt das bedeutet
dass es hochqualifizierte menschen sind
die für diese unternehmen arbeiten die
aus entweder aus der politik kommen oder
selber aus den ganz hohen ebenen der
verwaltung das heißt es sind menschen
die genau wissen wie die mechanismen
hier funktionieren die noch ein
gefülltes adressbuch haben
aber wer sind diese menschen die google
facebook und co die türen in die
hinterzimmer der politik öffnen
etwa die hälfte aller google lobbyisten
in brüssel war zuvor dem im parlament
tätig auch facebook weiß politiker innen
zu schätzen
ora sala bevor sie vor gut einem jahr zu
facebook ging arbeitete sie für den vize
präsidentin der eu kommission julian
reus sie wurde direkt aus dem
bundeskanzleramt rekrutiert dort war sie
bis vor kurzem die rechte hand der
digital ministerin dorothee bär
ein weiteres besonders prominentes
beispiel nick clegg einst parteichef der
levels und unter david cameron
vize-premier von großbritannien jetzt
facebook chef lobbyist in brüssel
und diese menschen werden auch ganz klar
eingesetzt also ich war wenige monate
abgeordnete und ich hatte schon eine
einladung zum abendessen von nick clegg
die ich nicht angenommen habe aber ich
weiß nicht wie es die kolleginnen und
kollegen handhaben millionen an lobby
ausgaben eingekaufte ex politiker innen
und ein immer größer werdender einfluss
auf gesetzgebungen sind wir den
konzernen mittlerweile ausgeliefert tech
unternehmen schreiben nicht ihre eigenen
gesetze aber es ist wichtig dafür darauf
zu achten dass der einfluss nicht größer
wird und dass wir insbesondere mit
transparenz reagieren
timo wolken sitzt für die
sozialdemokraten im eu-parlament und
arbeitet am dsl er kritisiert das
harsche vorgehen der unternehmen
andererseits gibt es zum beispiel den
fall google die haben massiv versucht
sozusagen das ansehen eines kommissars
von herrn breton zu anzugehen und zu
reduzieren und solche strategien sind
natürlich absolut zu verurteilen
wie google versucht härtere auflagen zu
torpedieren wird aus einem internen
dokument ersichtlich das uns vorliegt
in dem papier wird eine 60 tage
strategie entworfen
einer der zentralen punkte darin den
eu-kommissar thierry breton
zurückzudrängen
triton hatte zuvor wiederholt mit der
zerschlagung des netzgiganten gedroht
es ist extrem selten mal zu sehen
schwarz auf weiß wie lobbyismus
eigentlich abläuft
anfang april macht facebook erneut
schlagzeilen unbekannten ist es gelungen
persönliche daten von über 500 millionen
facebook nutzer innen abzugreifen
ein digitaler super gau weder facebook
noch google wollten vor der kamera mit
uns über ihre lobby aktivitäten sprechen
in brüssel werden zwar die gesetze
gemacht die unsere daten schützen sollen
aber dafür dass die am ende auch
eingehalten und die unternehmen zur
rechenschaft gezogen werden dafür muss
irland sorgen denn die offiziellen sitze
dieser tech giganten in europa befinden
sich in dublin
ich mache mich auf den weg nach irland
trotz corona und quarantäne
denn ich will unbedingt mit der chefin
der irischen datenschutzbehörde reden
auf meine zahlreichen anfragen hin bin
ich zwar immer nur vertröstet worden
aber versuchen will ich es trotzdem
meine quarantänezeit in dublin nutze ich
zur recherche
ich spreche mit expertinnen aus ganz
europa politiker innen
regulierungsbehörden bürgerrechtler
darunter auch max schrems gründer einer
datenschutzorganisation aus wien seit
bald zehn jahren versucht der jurist
einblick in seine facebook daten zu
erhalten
habe ich denn als eu-bürger licht ein
recht zu erfahren was facebook über mich
weiß und auch speichern ja es gibt es
recht auf auskunft und damit kann man
eigentlich verlangen eine volle kopie
aller daten zu bekommen und auch zum
beispiel woher die daten kommen und wenn
die weitergegeben werden
das recht hat jeder muss innerhalb von
einem monat beantwortet werden wie kann
das sein dass facebook einfach sagt das
ist uns egal ob man das ist doch
geltendes recht papier geduldig viel
kann sich ähnlichen gesetzen stehen wenn
es am ende nicht durchgesetzt wird und
das ist das kernproblem des europäischen
datenschutzes dass wir das sehr gerne
programmieren und sagen wir sind die
größten datenschützer der welt aber wenn
es am ende überhaupt nicht durchgesetzt
wird und da ist die irische behörde halt
zuständig und die will einfach nicht ich
mache mich auf den weg zum alten hafen
in dublin
hier haben sich die großen tech
unternehmen angesiedelt
in rekordzeit wurden gigantische
bürogebäude und luxuriöse
appartementanlagen hochgezogen die
gegend nennt man jetzt zilliken dogs
[Musik]
und das ist die irische
datenschutzbehörde die die multi
milliarden dollar konzern aus dem
silicon valley in die schranken weisen
soll
ich mache mich auf den weg dorthin so
wir sind jetzt eine gute autostunde von
dublin entfernt mitten hinein in das
irische heartland gefahren was ich mich
frage ist wie kann man ausgerechnet eine
der wichtigsten eu-behörden hierhin
versetzen portal linken rund 8000
einwohner ein paar ladengeschäfte und
offizieller sitz der irischen
datenschutzbehörde bis vor kurzem die
einzige anlaufstelle für datenschutz
beschwerden von rund 450 millionen
eu-bürgerinnen mittlerweile leistet sich
die behörde auch eine zweigstelle im
doppel
das ist ja also unsere last line of
defense für alle unsere daten die dann
nach amerika wann ich hätte als die
anwaltskanzleien von facebook oder von
google diese heute hier gesehen haben
die lachen bestimmt immer noch zurück in
dublin
ich schaue mir auch die zweite
dependance der datenschutzbehörde an
aufgrund der pandemie sind die büros
verweist
[Musik]
wie geht's jetzt ganz gut ich bin jetzt
zurück aus brüssel wie läuft's bei dir
und die halten uns immer noch hin wegen
des interviews also es ist echt es ist
ehrlich gesagt habe ich noch nie erlebt
aber wir sind weiter dran hier und hat
manchen also keine zeit mal geht's mal
geht es nicht sondern sagen die reden
sie sich raus wegen corona dabei ist das
überhaupt kein hinderungsgrund also wir
sind ja hier aber ich bleibe da dran
fast vier wochen mehrere telefonate und
25 textnachrichten nach meiner ersten
anfrage stimmt die chefin der irischen
datenschutzbehörde einem interview vor
der kamera endlich zu hellen dixon ist
diejenige die die tech konzerne zur
verantwortung ziehen und dafür sorgen
könnte dass geltendes europäisches recht
auch umgesetzt wird
wir treffen uns auf einem parkplatz in
einem vorort von dublin
[Musik]
konzerne die mit unseren daten
milliarden verdienen aber denen unsere
rechte ziemlich egal sind und eine
datenschutzbehörde die dabei einfach zu
schaut mich überzeugt das nicht und
viele andere offenbar auch nicht zum
beispiel sheridan der anwalt aus dublin
vertritt menschen die von facebook
google und co wissen wollen welche daten
die konzerne über sie gesammelt haben
unser weg führt uns nach brüssel
wir haben erfahren dass ein konsequentes
politisches handeln unverzichtbar ist um
die entfesselte macht der tech konzerne
zu regulieren und politik im sinne der
menschen zu gestalten
um zu verstehen warum unsere sensiblen
daten nicht besser geschützt werden sind
wir nach irland gereist
wir konnten sehen wie die tech konzerne
die partikularinteressen einzelner eu
mitgliedsländer geschickt gegeneinander
ausspielen wir haben erfahren dass man
zwar nicht von einer onlinesucht
sprechen kann aber dass soziale medien
trotzdem einfluss auf unsere mentale
gesundheit haben können und das social
media letztlich auch zu einer gefahr für
unsere demokratie werden kann
was also tun den stecker ziehen die apps
löschen offline gehen ist das die lösung
was muss passieren in unserer welt die
schon längst nicht mehr zwischen online
und offline unterscheidet
mein ideal für die sozialen medien ist
dass sie so funktionieren die ein echter
marktplatz ist alle menschen dort
teilhaben können ohne angst vor hass und
hetze wir dürfen die fragen was für ein
internet wir in zukunft nutzen wollen
nicht einzelnen finanzstarken digital
konzernen überlassen meine utopie für
social media ist mehr realität und
weniger inhalte die auf
persönlichkeitsprofil wo die würde ist
zu respektieren die meinungsfreiheit
jeder muss ich körperlich unversehrt
entwickeln können und man lebt friedlich
miteinander
eine utopie obwohl ich bewusst bin ist
medienkompetenz eine jüngere menschen
vermitteln so dass sie vielleicht in
einigen jahren ganz anders über genau
diese dinge verhandeln können
[Musik]